permettez monsieur certainement vous et
moi c'est ainsi c'est très difficile de
trouver une table
oui enfin je pourrai toujours aller en
face mais l'ambiance n'est pas la même
oui c'est six mois agréable et on dirait
que c'est tout le monde allait en face
c'est ainsi que ce ne serait pas gay
absolument
selon monsieur permettait garçon admis
je voudrais vous demander est ce que le
garçon est aussi pour vous qui sert à
mes amis n'est qu'à du pardon donc je je
voulais vous demander si le garçon était
aussi pour vous qui sert à mes racisme
huchet dans le gaz bec jour une excuse
il ya un brouillard très dense qu'à
faire je suis confus je n'ai toujours
pas compris savoir si dans ce cas fait
aussi le garçon était qui serra mais
rabat agri par l'étrange choc des merdes
à bob gainey
oui que le recul que le garçon ait des
votes dans non écoutez je vais vous dire
est ce que vous savez c'est pourrais me
rendre et ceram et rappelé mace dégâts
l'amour
certaines m'ont certainement y est
certainement on va papa soir donné
l'émoi que je vous donne oui bah oui
donnez moi je lui porte et lui porter
quoi les dix mille francs allez les dix
mille francs et un les dix mille francs
jamais excusé moi je vais pas tout de
suite compris leurs excuses à voir oui
mais alors voilà les pardons et bassa
par exemple non mais il ma cravate et de
digba aubin
salut je viens pas encore en matière une
petite seconde berry je t'en prie
justement je voulais parler alors dit
moi je voulais de savoir si pour toi
aussi le garçon était qui sert à maera
munich a dû oui quoi je voulais te
demander simplement si si le garçon
était simulé dans le glass bec
oui dis donc tu es ab a nommé rien du
tout mais non je te pose une question
bien simple je voudrais savoir si le
garçon était pour toi 30 choc devait
retenir oui d'accord d'accord d'accord
mendier est alors alors dû me les donne
que je lui porte
oui je lui porte quoi les dix mille
francs ah oui justement 1
à ce sujet je voulais te dire de petits
mots voilà tu connais pas tu tu sais la
fille avec qui je sors en ce moment
c'est son anniversaire
alors si je ne trouve pas dix mille
balles avant ce soir je suis foutu tu
comprends ce n'est qu'une femme je suis
obligée de temps en temps d'avoir un
petit geste tu comprends oui je trouve
pas dix mille balles avant ce cas
comment veux tu que le nom maintenant
mais je tenais un peu tard en juillet tu
sais moi ça me dérange pas je suis déçu
non plus ici je n'en ai pas ce que je
peux pas voir dans cet état là non